randy is a home run of a question bro
ever been at a monster truck
extravaganza in 1985
and when you ask your dad to buy
earplugs he rips the filter off two
marlboros and sticks it in your ears
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
randy how old of a fella are you
i said how old are you randy 42 nice
so you were like [ __ ] four years old
or something like that
put cigarette butts in your ears
work like a charm though i'll tell you
that right now what if i didn't hear his
name earlier on
goddamn 85 little [ __ ] monster
trucking scrub what'd you say
did you say andy or randy you got to
speak up you got to speak up all i hear
is grave digger
i'm randy
and i love bigfoot
goddamn randy that is a [ __ ] home run
and you're awesome man give him a round
of applause
god damn
shout out to big roger too
[Applause]
all right let's uh let's do one more
here is
the emails chris cleans cars
chris
chris you're here
awesome what's up all the way in the
back how are you doing
you know what
we never do this why don't you come up
on stage
come on up here craigslist
his name is chris clean's cars for fun
we've been wanting to try it
who you win
[Applause]
bring up your girlfriend [ __ ] it let's
go
come on up sweetheart we're not gonna
make fun of this
cause your question is insane dude yeah
this is wild
give me a nice round of applause for the
coming up everybody
get up here
what's up man you gotta love the tank
top to the comedy show too hi how are
you nice to meet you great look give me
a pound give me a pack come on up here
kevin nice to meet you what's up bro
guys give a big round of applause come
on in here chris
oh cool all right so
instead of him reading the question
why don't you go ahead and read the
question
yeah
okay all right um
my question was
trashy or classy
is it
bad or is it trashy or classy to bring
your pregnant girlfriend to a comedy
show
to propose to her
go for it big man
go for it
[Applause]
somebody got that goddamn limbo
we [ __ ] love each and every one of
you
god damn
[Applause]
one more time guys let them [ __ ] hear
it [ __ ] that was awesome congratulations
guys
congratulations guys up front we can't
wait